Your grandmother. Today you're a
grandmother yourself. Are you like her?
-Well...
-She was an important person.
I sometimes think about this.
She was a very strict, pedantic-
-and industrious woman.
I think have inherited
some of those things.
Pedantry can be both good and bad.
But I have that.
-You clean a lot?
-You'll always see me with my duster...
I'm a pedant in many other respects
as well. In life, simply.
And so was she. She brought me up,
so of course I copied her-
-and was shaped by her way of being,
towards herself and towards me too.
-Are you strict as well?
-No, I'm a kind person.
But sometimes I'm exacting.
It depends on the situation.
But your husband -
we met him backstage - Henry...
-Is he like you?
-No, he's the opposite.
-I see.
-It's a good combination.
-Yes, but...
-Can you relate to this?
-Do you correct him sometimes?
-He said that?
I'm just...
Yes, I do correct him sometimes.
But not in a...
I do so in a friendly manner.
-I'm a super-pedant myself.
-So, you get me.
One-hundred-percent. Look around.
It's really nice and tidy here.
-You're very diligent.
-It's so beautiful.
-It is.
-It's really important.
You sing, you write
and you design clothes.
Yes, and it's such fun.
A couple of years ago, when I realized I
was quite done with singing, I thought:
"What would I like to replace it with?"
And I need to do something creative.
I've always liked design.
And since I spend so much time
out in nature, skiing-
-so, what are my thoughts
on today's ski outfits? They're boring.
They're quite unisex.
Very practical, of course.
But I wanted to go back to the more
feminine ski suit from the 70's.
-ABBA-clothes?
-Yes, we did wear such suits, yes.
-Björn Ulvaeus had one of those...
-I wasn't thinking about ABBA.
I was thinking about when I went skiing.
-And then...
-It was all about air resistance.
Really? Well...
Yes, it's quite fast, sometimes.
Anyways, I designed a ski suit.
Of the rather exclusive kind.
I'm very pleased with it.
And then I asked around if anybody'd be
interested in producing it for me.
I didn't want to do that myself.
A fashion company in Sweden was
interested. They're also international.
We'll launch the outfits
in December of this year.
-Your ski outfits.
-Yes.
You've been praised a lot
for your business skills.
You've made good investments and...
-Both yes and no, really.
-Sure. Those things go up and down.
But you've been good at handling
your economy.
It goes hand in hand with the pedantry.
Did you use to be different?
I was more spendthrift.
I liked shopping and things.
When you've never had any money
it's fun, naturally.
But I'm as careful now, as when
I travelled to Norway as a child-
-and collected pennies in a bag
that I brought with me to buy candy.
But I couldn't use Swedish pennies in
Norway, so somebody else had to pay.
You have fans all over the world.
They sent us messages
before your arrival.
Do you become friends
with them over time?
Or do you send them a polite reply
and that's it?
I've become friends with some of them
and remain in contact with them.
There is one fan in particular.
He contacted me four years ago.
I was very moved by his story.
He's of simple origins. He was about 60
years old when he started writing to me.
He trained as a butcher at sixteen
and when the foot-and-mouth disease-
-hit England in 2002-
-he was called upon by the authorities
to help slaughter the sick cattle.
It was a horrible time for him-
-because he had to slaughter
all these animals-
-in a very particular way and also had
to share these families' griefs-
-and their loss
of their means of livelihood.
This resulted
in his getting deeply depressed-
-and he eventually decided
to take his own life.
He was about to go through with it.
He took his favourite ABBA-tape
and his gun-
-and went out to end it all.
Just as he's ready, ABBA:s singing:
"The Way Old Friends Do".
He stops and listens to the these lyrics
and he's thinking:
"This is exactly how life is."
You need to be with your friends-
-and you need to help each other out,
the way old friends do.
He'd left his wife without a word,
of course.
He had children and grandchildren.
He had a big family.
So, he changed his mind,
because of this song.
He went back to his wife
and told her everything.
And then I received a letter
where he told me this whole story.
We continued to correspond.
I was very moved, of course.
I replied with a long
and friendly letter.
And then we continued to keep in
contact. He'd write me once a month.
He'd tell me about his life,
his family, his friends-
-his hobbies - everything.
He was a wonderful writer.
And then what happened was
- he got lung cancer.
And he passed away last February
and that was very sad.
-It was great having you here, Frida.
-Thank you.
All the way from Switzerland
- here's Frida.